a vida aqui do time
[Música]
e aí galera que existe um canal com
vocês para novidade barbosa neder
prometem perguntar se estão bem tá bom
tá bom que os 4 discussões interessantes
semana a primeira um juiz dizendo que
queria bloquear whatsapp para bloqueá
las vegas ela pega vem da pink mas é
também fingir que não está bem na tomada
cara vai ter um macho que isto matar que
é fã da mamãe é a segunda é o que é o
vestido que muda de cor quais qual é a
cor do vestido é branco e dourado ou é
preto e azul gente entenda uma coisa não
importa a cor do vestido você diz que
está bonita é meu espelho que tapeia e
troca todo esse acordo não importa é
outra notícia qual é nosso canal chegou
a 2 milhões de inscritos a isi isso é
assunto pra outro vídeo que eu vou fazer
especialmente pra você e de 2 milhões a
outra notícia é a que me deixa mais
feliz de todos dela gente eu finalmente
a um meio de ter essa semana finalmente
eu criei coragem para os dentes porque
eu era uma pessoa que não tinha raiva de
chute a ódio eu tinha muito ódio de
serviço um carro melhor carro lindo da
minha vida ouvi no meio da rua a paz que
carro lindo meu amigo que estava
perfeito na mão de quem se está a passar
disse a dentista não podem estribar
adventista de tv que vou estar todo o
diabo da artista o diabo e minha mãe
fosse um dentista andar nem bem saiu
aquela máquina e aqui é do demônio que
danielle sá anai aquela maquininha é tão
do belmonte se você pega você gravar com
ela só tinha botado computador rodar o
contrário a música da xuxa é do demônio
é pobre porque o dente a pé do ouvido
país
escuto tudo eo pé do ouvido à vontade
para falar desse rapaz não tinha um
barulho pior que ouvir não deixe de
rapaz que um cd do pablo aqui
não não não me deixe só eu gosto dessas
há ninguém mais normal deixa falar assim
aí vamos começar a pagar pela maquininha
o senhor antônio
eu tinha medo de liberty city assim como
dorothy um pouca da boca agora a máquina
que já pra [ __ ] o outro porque como
eu tinha medo de dentista eu ficava
muito tempo sem dentes eu tinha medo de
ir ao dentista e ver o que ia encontrar
na minha boca vamos ver como essa boca
de chuva que lixa curandeira e dar bem
que uma atualização do avast acabei de
achar um cavalo de tróia bem que nem
tinha medo também de passar vergonha em
gastar muito tempo procurando vaga de
titi vai querer alguma coisa e vamos lá
ver como é que essa boquinha memória
fiscal prudente não é meu lado de maria
votassem na pico contaminada mas também
o de tite vai a minha boca assim para
ver como é que essa boquinha uma ameaça
foi detectada e já vira bem aí que o
vasco deu certo não lembro de uma vez
que eu passei muito tempo no dentista e
eu vi que tinha ficado um negócio em
preto número 2 mas só uma coisa menino
quando cheguei no dentista que este
homem foi acidente que ele olhou que
estava preto preto tão preto ganhou no
fundo dec2 ramadã capoeirão e falou
assim para mim meu filho você abre um
canal falei eu tenho no youtube seja
quem se inscreveu é o meu filho você tem
canal para adotou eu tenho um canal em
que o rapaz com esse canal só pode ser a
globo que só tem lixo país está passando
é big brother eu me sentia humilhado ao
meu problema não era isso que quando é
assim você pode no dentista ele conserva
seu dente faz um canal faz um curativo
obturação a coisa e dá um jeito por um
tempo meu problema é que eu tinha um
dente torto e assistimos antigo que é
companheiro e sabe a situação que era
esses meus de [ __ ] que pariu doente era
muito tornar macho do samba do dente era
muito não terá tão torpe que eu estava
com medo se tivesse alguém perto de mim
eu mal chegava a minha comida ea comida
do colega ao mesmo tempo eu nem era tão
torto minha surpresa quando nascer na
nuca tubarão a ficar com raiva de mim
que tinha mais gente que era dente de
marina bay namorada e me beija flor não
acreditar mas dentro quando eu sorri a
galera fazer assim não pegar nem aí o
que aconteceu estava rodando não está
grande e está ganhando tirulipa que o
eleitor se dirija ao amigo dele próprio
ok o livro foi imprudente rapaz é uma
dentista de fortaleza que o seu que bota
tudo lugar fazer só isso assim aí um
pouco a lei agora eu vou dar um desafio
com essa mulher porque eles vêm aqui é
servir para três pedreiras 7 servente
aqui vai se mentiu para iaquinta
resultado pra você
yane ganha agora de bem quanto tempo eu
fiz acidente dois dias não tem
recuperação você já sai com medo que
quiser pode beber coca pode beber café
pode beber comer bosta que fica da mesma
cor
a gente agora sério sem brincadeira eu
queria muito que agradecer a doutora
wagner diniz por ter feito isso pra mim
por ter me devolvido a minha felicidade
e acima de tudo eu sorri porque eu
realmente tinha muito tinha muita
vergonha de sorrir no meio do povo
sorrir 5 a galera porque o chato todo
mundo não só reúne todo mundo tem 11
numa terra bonita para mostrar talento é
bom que o resto da tela não é tão bonita
assim mas pelo menos dentro tem noção de
como eu saí desse consultório eu sair
assim uma pessoa ligada à sorriso uma
palavra de lixo passava lata do lixo
podia ser a pior piada do mundo era uma
vez um piquete ele espera ele foi se
cair não caiu
eu queria fazer aqui um pedido à vocês
vocês que me seguem a vocês ficarão
felizes por mim aqui na descrição do
vídeo tem o instagram da doutora que fez
o mesmo dentro ela posta desde aquela
paz inclusive postou meu tem caso você
fica assim pô você fica besta é quanto à
formação eu queria pedir encarecidamente
a todos vocês que seguissem a doutora no
instagram e uma forma de agradecimento
assim pra mim tá e o que vai influenciar
a gente vai influenciar muita coisa ela
me deixou feliz o que você deixar sem
ela ele e aí por tabela pode ter gente
assim com o mesmo problema que o que
tinham medo de sorrir ligado pode ser
você não pode ser seu pai pode ser só
tinha pode ser alguém então vai lá e por
mim segue ela não posso esquecer
não posso esquecer de dizer que vou
mostrar os meus dentes em recife pe
dia 14 às 6 horas lá no teatro boa vista
e reflita a vender ingresso na pm entrou
lá no shopping riomar gente lá no térreo
e para quem é de bolinhas vai receber
assistir lá no bompreço olinda também
está vendendo tá se você se divertir se
você gostou do vídeo é que você faz e
curtir no facebook aqui no youtube
clique em gostei no twitter você da rtp
para mais gente vê que não está a dança
e curte a foto de divulgação estou feliz
estou muito feliz então arcada dentária
nova eu vou medir até meu beijo amiga na
boca de sakineh qualquer um beijo uma
máquina foi pedir bessa tbs benfica
beijar minha mão beijada moto mas não
pelo amor de deus vou jogar na minha
boca e me beija muito obrigado a ser
seguido até aqui na globo barra do dande